well tfl is arguably one of the safest
and cleanest at transit authorities
in the world we're using world-class
enhanced cleaning
we're using hospital quality
disinfectant we've got more than a
thousand hand sanitizers we're using
uv light to make sure our escalators are
safe we're also asking imperial college
to come and make sure
there's no covet on public transport
they found no evidence of coving or the
testing they've done
but i think after monday we should
continue making it
compulsory to wear a face mask on public
transport where often you can't keep
your social
distance it adds an additional layer of
protection but also
reassurance the evidence we know from
the government's
own scientific advices the evidence from
the world health organization
is you are in a face mask makes it less
likely
that the virus can be passed on it
reduces transmission in an indoor space
where you can't keep your distance but
also the center for disease control in
the usa have now said actually on top of
it being the most unselfish thing you
can do we're in a face mask may reduce
the chances of you catching the virus so
for me
it's really important that we make sure
public transport continues to be both
safe but also reassuring how confident
are you though that londoners will
will heed uh the tfl guidance i i mean
at the plural of anecdote is not
evidence of course
but my travels on public transport last
week would certainly suggest
that already in the aftermath of the
announcement about july the 19th there
are a lot of people
choosing not to wear masks
yeah that's why i was keen to come out
today before monday
and make it clear what the expectation
is going to be after monday which is a
continuation
of it being obligatory to wear a face
mask when you're using uh
transport in uh london the good news is
uh from survey work we've uh done over
the last year
uh roughly speaking 86 86 of people
using public transport in london
are we in face coverings and of the 14
who aren't
about two-thirds are either exempt or
have a good reason my message to anybody
not just in london
but those visiting our cities it is
going to be compulsory store from next
monday
to our face cover and actually you know
what's the most unselfish thing you can
do it means that there's less chance
if you've got the virus and by the way
one out of three people who've got the
virus won't show any symptoms
it reduces the chance of you passing it
on is there going to be
robust enforcement of this are we going
to see bus drivers kicking people off
buses not letting them all in the first
place
tfl employees being asked to confront
people
at train stations or is this simply just
a statement of intent if the maid of
london says wear your masks on public
transport
there is a greater likelihood that
people will wear mass on public
transport
well what i've examined over the last
year what's been going on in
london and roughly speaking there have
been 212 000
conversations between tfl enforcement
officers
and members of the public by and large
members of the public put on their face
masks in their pocket or their purse
they've forgotten
it's not quite covering their nose or
sometimes they'll go to the shop and get
one before they get on a bus
or a network actually has only been 4
000
fixed penalty notices issued so what
you're going to be seeing from
monday is we've got hundreds of tfl
enforcement officers they'll be there to
make sure people are following the rules
but if you come to a station or you want
to go on a bus and you haven't got a
face covering
you may not be allowed on without a face
covering unless you're exempt
if you're on one of our trains tubes
buses ducklings like railway
overground trains tfl rail and you'll
see not to have a face mask
and you've got a good reason and you
aren't exempt you'll be asked to leave
so can i just just dwell on this topic
just for a second i think there's around
about 400 tfl enforcement officers
as you say thousands of of penalties
have been issued i think
just a little bit less than 5 000. that
strikes me that's one a month over the
past year
for each of those enforcement officers
are we going to see
more penalty notices handed out
i hope not because you know the evidence
is is londoners and those visiting our
city have done the right thing
and not just the huge sacrifices made
over the last 16 months but over the
last 12 months
uh making the right choice to wear a
face mask without the need
for enforcement to take place but if
there is a need for greater enforcement
if there's a need for
more tearful enforcement officers we'll
look into that at the same time we're
exploring
uh making this a bylaw that'll mean we
can use both the police service
uh in london but also british transport
police but you know the evidence i've
seen
is people doing the right thing you know
brits and londoners get it and they want
to be unselfish they want to
avoid the chance minimize the chance of
them passing the virus but also they're
well aware
that amongst us there are people with
clinical vulnerabilities there are some
of us whose immunity is suppressed
we don't want them to be not being able
to use an essential service like public
transport and so i'm confident
londoners and those visionaries will do
the right thing i i want to talk about
what happened in and around
wembley in just a second but perhaps we
could focus on what followed
the football on on sunday and tyrone
ming's and others actually within the
england setup have suggested
that perhaps people in including the
home secretary pretty patel
fueled the fire uh in terms of the
racist abuse that they received i'm sure
that in the past you may well have in
private referred to the conservatives as
the nasty party
i'm just wondering whether you think
they're a racist party
well let me be quite clear one of the
reasons
why the likes of marcus rashford raheem
sterling and others felt so strongly
about black lives matter and support
with the movement
was to say no to racism and one of the
reasons why the likes of harry maguire
harry kane and others supported their
colleagues when it came to taking the
knee
was to show solidarity uh in their fight
against
racism and i think when people boo that
boo their own team
it begs the question about some of their
motives and to not condem
boone of our players taking the knee to
not condemn that i think
doesn't bode well but also you know what
harry kane's not a marxist
harry mcguire doesn't want to defund the
police these are
colleagues showing solidarity to their
black mates in the squad and i'm really
proud of
the squad i'm really proud of gareth
southgate i'm really proud of the team
and those who have been hurling racist
abused online
on the stands or on the street should be
disgusted and i'm sure the police will
be taking action
in terms of what we saw at wembley and
indeed what we saw in the west end uh
cameron mackintosh complaining about the
windham theater you know requiring you
know essentially millions of pounds
worth of repairs
because of the behavior of fans why do
we keep hearing so many people say that
they have full confidence in crested
decks running of the metropolitan police
well the responsibility for the fans in
leicester square
in liverpool street outside wembley
stadium
in parts of london lies with the
hooligans and it's really important that
they're held to account
more than 86 arrests already been made
19 of our police officers were
injured and the police are going through
both cctv footage
are going through body worn videos are
looking at the evidence and more charges
will be
brought because the sort of hooliganism
you saw on sunday isn't acceptable and
it's really important they're brought to
book
but there are no questions about chris
dedick's continuing as head of the met
well now she's got almost a year left of
her contract she's got my full
confidence
it's for the commissioner to decide
whether she wants a second term let's
cross that bridge when it comes to it
but it's really important that we
support the police
in relation to catching those criminals
responsible for this sort of behavior
on a sunday as far as i'm concerned
they're not real fans
and it's really really really important
if anybody's got information about any
hooligans on
sunday then let the police know because
we want justice to happen
sadiq khan good to see you this morning
thanks for being with us
stay safe